[Music]
everybody is Charlie even though it's
trailer city this week a lot of you
requested a video for the New Avengers
for art that just dropped so careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen infinity
war yet there's a new round of that
infinity war blu-ray giveaway all you
have to do to enter is be a subscriber
and leave a comment on the video so
there's actually a couple of pictures of
both the New Avengers roster and Thanos
but the New Avengers stuff is really
where all the important stuff is so some
of the returning characters have gotten
additional upgrades this is meant to be
the same pose as age of Ultron when
they're all flying across the screen and
formation I hope there's a shot like
this in the Avengers 4 trailer this
feels like something that they would
shoot for the trailer specifically even
if they change it a little bit by the
time it gets to the final movie but just
going from left to right Thor is flying
with Stormbreaker he doesn't look any
different than he did right after the
finger-snap for those asking yes he did
fly without the hammer during Ragnarok
but the whole joke was is that the
hammer helped channel his power so it
was always him doing the flying not the
hammer lifting him up like he said
Stormbreaker is no different in that
regard we finally get to see Captain
Marvel in her new costume flying right
next to Thor remember even though her
power source is different she can fly
just like he can we could spend all day
talking about her powers and the new
backstory that they've created for her
there's actually a comic book coming out
really soon that will tell what that new
origin story is so I'll do a video for
it when it drops but because she can
absorb and redirect energy and they like
to combine Avengers powers for funny
moments during big battles I'm really
hoping that the Russos have Thor blast
her with storm breaker or Iron Man's
gauntlets so that she could charge up
before their big fight with Thanos again
I've already done a couple videos about
Captain Marvel but all of her Avengers 4
scenes were shot before they started
shooting the Captain Marvel movie so
we'll get to watch her go from the green
Crete uniform in that red blue variant
that we see in this by the end of the
Captain Marvel movie but in the same way
Spider Man got his new stark tech suit
they're doing the same thing for her she
got the suit for Avengers 4 first they
designed it for that but she's going to
be wearing it for the first time
chronologically in Captain Marvel
since everybody gets big costume upgrade
for the New Avengers films I'll be
interested to see if they give her a
costume change for Avengers 5 whenever
that ends up dropping but in this
picture right here you'll notice that
she's not wearing the sash so maybe she
loses that after the end of the Captain
Marvel movie because she has it in the
Captain Marvel promo art that they
released way back at Comic Con last year
so I'm guessing the costume has a little
more fidelity to classic Captain Marvel
during her movie and then it gets a
little more pared down for Avengers for
nebulas still alive so of course she
joined the team but does that really
make her an Avenger just because she's
fighting with them not really but you
could call her an honorary Avenger just
for the duration of Avengers 4 before
she goes back into outer space with the
Guardians Iron Man's armor doesn't look
any different in this picture but that
doesn't mean that things don't change
for him between infinity war and when
they fixed the universe because if he's
one of my top candidates to wield the
new Infinity Gauntlet to fix everything
so if he's gonna do that he's gonna have
to channel the power to the gems it will
require another upgrade I'm assuming he
doesn't have his wings deployed because
it would obscure the characters behind
him and this promo art is meant to show
you a version of what they'll look like
when they're fighting Thanos but down
here rocket doesn't have a gun he's just
jumping at dana's with his claws and
teeth it would be funny to see him
attack Thanos like a regular animal but
I think it's the same deal with Iron Man
like he would wield a comically
oversized gun and that would probably
obscure some of the characters behind
him so just because he's not wielding
anything in this doesn't mean he's not
gonna have something ridiculously huge
when they're fighting Thanos again but a
lot of you were really happy when you
saw that black widow had her red hair
back most of you noticed that she
doesn't have the ponytail I'm not
reading too much into that because this
is just supposed to be teaser art and
she cut her hair short before infinity
war I'm guessing she just kept it short
in Avengers 4 but she's still wearing
the exact same jumpsuit that she was
during infinity war Captain America's
look has changed quite a bit most of you
noticed that he's lost the beard he's
wearing a version of his scale armor
from the comics it's almost exactly like
his old armor with a couple minor tweaks
he's been wearing that since civil war
what had happened during infinity ward's
that by that time his armor had gotten
so worn down that you could see the
under layer the under layer is where the
scale armor is so it looks like you're
just more exposed here and they polished
it up
brighten the star again he doesn't have
his shield but that also doesn't mean
that he doesn't wield one because
remember during Homecoming Iron Man was
developing caps new prototype shield we
just got Tony's old Hulk Buster armor
prototype for caps new shield and the
making the mech the hook is probably the
biggest change everybody noticed it was
freaking out about this Hulk is actually
Hulk but he's wearing a full uniform and
he's not screaming like an animal it's
almost as if he's completely controlling
himself like Banner in the body of the
Hulk
so pretty safe bet that he's a version
of Professor Hulk the balance of banners
mind in the Hulk's power
now obviously the comic-book Professor
Oak was a little bit different I've
already done a video about that so I'll
link it at the end of this because
Professor Hulk is actually a combination
of three different characters in the
comics we finally see Hawkeye made the
team now you've probably noticed that I
used the Hawkeye purple Avengers 4 logo
that was actually the official logo that
they were using when they were shooting
Avengers 4 so that feels like Kevin
Feige in the Russos just sort of having
a little bit of fun with how everybody
was freaking out about Hawkeye last year
but obviously you'll notice that he
doesn't look like he's wearing the Ronan
armor from the comics that doesn't mean
that he's not going to be the Ronan
character like cap was the Nomad
character but he was still wearing his
old cap armor think of it as being like
that so technically he is the Ronan
character during Avengers 4 but you look
at war machine he has another minor
upgrade to his armor from infinity war
now his infinity war armor looked a
little bit like this so this is just
like a little more hardcore than that so
not too many big changes most of the
shots of him were deploying ordnance so
you didn't get to see whether or not it
actually did come out of the new legs
that Stark built for him I was really
hoping to get a shot of that but they
probably just opted to do it the cheap
way but then we have ant-man he doesn't
look any different than he does during
ant-man and the wasp we've seen some set
pics of him in costume walking around
with the other Avengers so it's
basically the exact same costume that he
wears during ant-man and the wasp but a
lot of you have speculated that this
place where they're fighting Thanos is
back on Titan but the rocks are all dark
blue so it's kind of the wrong color
I'm assuming it's somewhere else the
closest thing we've seen to this is the
place during Ironman
vision during age of Ultron you're not
the only one cursed with the knowledge
Stark but I always thought that that was
meant to be the place where they fought
him in infinity war even though at the
time it looked a little bit more like
sanctuary
we have new promo art for Thanos he
looks almost exactly like he did during
infinity war with the exception of the
double-edged sword a lot of people are
thinking that this is just a
merchandising thing like he had a sword
at some point when they were developing
infinity war but they got rid of it when
the Russos were like you know what
he doesn't need a sword if he has the
infinity gems he's already the most
powerful being in the universe the sword
would just be redundant so I wouldn't be
surprised if he doesn't have the sword
when they're fighting him again during
Avengers 4 but I do think that he'll be
wearing his armor like he hung it up at
the end of infinity war when he's on
Kimora's planet here's just chilling out
like think about it this way
Iron Man was barely able to scratch him
with all of his power Stormbreaker is
the only weapon we've seen that's been
able to pierce his armor so if you're
wondering why that is Stormbreaker has
enchantments so yes it's more powerful
than a normal weapon it's more powerful
than his hammer but is also made from
the same guru metal as Stannis's armor
is so just remember it's the same deal
with Black Panthers claws being able to
scratch Captain America's shield they're
both made of vibranium and Thanos's
armor was forged by each wreath in the
dwarves a long time before he forced him
to make the Infinity Gauntlet so he's
been wearing this for a long time in the
dwarves build weapons for other people
besides the ass Guardians but just in
general I think this scene is meant to
be something from later in the movie
because you don't go from banner versus
Hulk in infinity war like having a
problem turning back into the Hulk to
Professor Hulk overnight so you have to
have these awkward introductions with
Captain Marvel Captain Ironman have to
make up Hawkeye has to roll in so early
prediction because all that stuff has to
happen before they fight together we
don't see them all fighting in formation
with Thanos until the third act of the
film
I don't know when they've scheduled
reshoots 4 but there's a lot of people
that have been seeing pictures that look
like the original battle of New York
like they're redoing scenes from the
Battle of New York for Avengers 4 but
that might just be part of the VAR
effing scenes that the Russos talked
about earlier but what I'm hoping for is
that we're gonna get a Captain Marvel
teaser trailer sometime at the end of
the summer and then a little while after
that they'll let us know what the
Avengers 4 title is it will get a small
teaser for that but the really
interesting thing that you may have
noticed is that the Russos
have completely wiped their social media
clean so I think when they start posting
again that's when we'll start seeing
Avengers for stuff congratulations to
the latest giveaway winner Don Ray Tony
oh please private message me so I can
get your contact details click here to
rewatch that new Spider Man into the
spider-verse trailer and click here for
that Professor Hulk video thank you so
much for watching everybody stay awesome
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]